[Musik]
viele interessen ein ziel in berlin
suchen verbündete und gegner nach einer
lösung für den blutigen konflikt in
libyen keine pflichten keine privilegien
mit dem royalen rückzug müssen prinz
harry und herzog in meggen ihre
königliche titel ruhen lassen
entscheidet die queen große enttäuschung
kaum noch hoffnung nach der niederlage
gegen kroatien zeigen sich die deutschen
handballer kämpferisch
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
unseren nachrichtenüberblick am sonntag
bei dem auch der sport nicht fehlt
christian otto ist da genau sehr gerne
und wir beginnen natürlich mit dem
großereignis in berlin heute der libyen
konferenz von kanzlerin merkel zu der
sie alle angereist sind die großen und
die kleineren mächte die dort ihre
finger im spiel haben seit es den
autokratischen machthaber gaddafi nicht
mehr gibt aber bevor wir über die
konferenz und ihre ziele berichten
erklärt erst einmal tim rhomberg worum
es in libyen geht seit dem sturz von
machthaber gaddafi 2011 konnte sich in
libyen keine stabile zentralregierung
her durchsetzen
zwar gibt es eine international
anerkannte regierung unter der führung
von ministerpräsident al faraj ihr macht
bereich beschränkt sich allerdings auf
wenige gebiete rund um die hauptstadt
tripolis
ein viel größerer teil libyens wird vom
abtrünnigen general haffter und seinen
truppen kontrolliert ein dauerhafter
waffenstillstand zwischen den
kontrahenten wäre ein wichtiger erster
schritt für eine lösung der krise
dabei kommt es auch auf die jeweiligen
verbündeten an zu den unterstützern der
regierung zählen die türkei italien und
katar auf der seite von haffter stehen
unter anderem russland ägypten und die
vereinigten arabischen emirate europa
hat großes interesse an stabilen
verhältnissen in dem nordafrikanischen
staat das land ist ein wichtiger
öllieferant und hunderttausende
flüchtlinge und migranten befinden sich
in libyen viele machen sich von hier aus
auf über das mittelmeer in richtung eu
tja und auch wegen der flüchtlinge hat
die kanzlerin ja so großes interesse
daran dass die konferenz heute ein
erfolg wird und die beiden wichtigsten
ziele erreicht ein ende der einmischung
von aussen und das dauerhafte schweigen
der waffen damit aus libyen nicht ein
zweites syrien wird weniger aus berlin
die welt ist zu gast in berlin und wer
der welt zeigen will dass ohne ihn
nichts geht der kommt zu spät
der türkische präsident erdogan 50
minuten der russische präsident putin
fast eine ganze stunde
die beiden männer haben sich vor dem
gipfel abseits in einem hotel zu einem
vier augen gespräch getroffen
sie unterstützen im krieg in libyen
unterschiedliche seiten putin sagt
russland und die türkei hätten sehr gute
schritte unternommen um die libyschen
kriegsparteien zu einer waffenruhe zu
bewegen
erdogan erwidert general haffter müsse
sein aggressives verhalten ändern damit
die anderen stufen des politischen
prozesses beginnen könnten
der general ist nur für einen kurzen
augenblick auf dem flur des kanzleramts
zu sehen er und der libysche premier
saad dürfen nicht an diesem gipfel
format teilnehmen
merkel & maaß hatten beide vor
abgetrennt getroffen verhandlungen also
ohne libyen über eine entwaffnung der
milizen ein waffenembargo und einen
umfassenden waffenstillstand renault
implementiert um die beschlüsse
umzusetzen müssen die europäer sich
stärker engagieren mehr als in der
vergangenheit
um das waffenembargo zu kontrollieren
man kann nicht erwarten dass der
waffenstillstand hält wenn die waffen
strömen nach libyen nicht kontrolliert
werde das familien foto zeigt die
herausforderungen dieses treffens hier
steht mancher staat aufgereiht der mit
waffenlieferungen oder truppen
entsendungen seine ganz eigenen
interessen in libyen verfolgt und wir
schalten nach berlin und kairo zu theo
koll und oligarch erstmal zu theo vor
dem kanzleramt
drinnen läuft die konferenz ja noch
sieht es denn nach einem erfolg aus kann
man das schon sagen nur die chancen für
eine einigung sollen jedenfalls nicht
schlecht sein ein teilnehmer meinte man
stehe kurz vor einer einigung auf den
entwurf einer abschlusserklärung
angestrebt ist die einigung auf einen
waffenstillstand und vor allem die
einhaltung des waffenembargos
letzteres soll so jedenfalls der entwurf
sogar mit sanktionen belegt werden
sollte das so kommen wäre es ein
wirklich bemerkenswerter erfolg auf der
diplomatischen bühnen aber der wirkliche
erfolg entscheidet sich weniger auf der
bühne als hinter bühnenvorhang also
werden sich diejenigen
wie ein wirtschaftlicher oder
geostrategische interessen haben an ihre
eigenen zusagen hier halten
und da sind zumindest zweifel erlaubt
und die frage an wie wird die konferenz
denn in der arabischen welt wahrgenommen
der mit großer aufmerksamkeit mit großer
ernsthaftigkeit man findet diese
konferenz gut für viele ist es im
prinzip die letzte ausfahrt vor einer
eskalation wie sie in syrien stattfindet
das will man auf jeden fall vermeiden
und hofft darauf dass die europäer sich
stärker engagieren in libyen
diese diese embargos die jetzt eben
angesprochen werden die wieder aufleben
sollen das alles sind wichtige dinge
aber die araber fragen sich wer wird
diese dinge auch tatsächlich robust
überwachen wer hat die kraft wer hat die
muskeln die zurechtzuweisen die
ausscheren und das sind immerhin nicht
kleine lichter der sind große große
leute große staatsseite wie putin die
als die eher seltener in libyen haben
oder oder erdogan
das sind gewichtige player wer sollte
ich im zaum halten falls die geschichte
wieder von vorne losgeht dass in fragen
die für die araber hier gewaltig
umtreibt
viele offene fragen auf beiden seiten
danke uli danke theo wissenswertes zur
bedeutung libyens für europa und die
welt können sie in unserem umfangreichen
themenpaket im internet nachlesen unter
heute.de außenminister maas hat die
drohgebärden und militäraktion von
us-präsident trump im iran konflikt
kritisiert es dürfe nicht so getan
werden als würde sich mit einem von
außen herbeigeführten regime wechsel in
teheran die lage automatisch verbessern
das sei woanders auch schon
schiefgegangen etwa im irak sagte maas
der bild am sonntag
nach dem flugzeugunglück nahe teheran
sind elf todesopfer in die ukraine
überführt worden
bei dem abschuss waren 176 insassen
gestorben
zur trauerfeier kam auch präsident sie
lenski
irans staatliche nachrichtenagentur
meldete dass die beiden flugschreiber
vorerst doch nicht an die ukraine
übergeben werden iran hatte die
passagiermaschine nach eigenen angaben
versehentlich abgeschossen
in großbritannien gibt es heute fast nur
ein thema es wird wohl ein harter max it
so titeln einige zeitungen
prinz harry und seine frau megan wollten
sich eigentlich nur teilweise von ihren
royalen pflichten zurückziehen doch
gestern abend teilte der buckingham
palast mit die beiden werden künftig
ihre titel königliche hoheit ruhen
lassen und keine termine für das
königshaus mehr wahrnehmen andreas
stammen aus london die queen lächelnd
auf dem weg zum gottesdienst nach einer
woche geprägt von krisengesprächen in
denen um die art und weise von harry und
megans rückzug gerungen wurde
in einer persönlichen erklärung gab die
queen gestern abend die einigung bekannt
das paar samt sohn archie wird künftig
größtenteils in kanada wohnen knapp drei
millionen euro steuergeld zurückzahlen
das für die renovierung ihres hauses
geflossen war
sie werden keine offiziellen aufgaben
mehr übernehmen ihre titel als
königliche hoheiten ruhen lassen die
erklärung der queen ist warmherzig sie
hebt hervor dass harry mergel und archie
immer ein geliebter teil der familie
sein werden aber auch sehr deutlich halt
drin hat draußen das geht nicht die
königin will einen sauberen schnitt
in zukunft dürfen harry und merken
selbst geld verdienen allerdings unter
auflagen die queen will ein wörtchen
mitreden so verhindern dass das paar
seine royale berühmtheit mit deals
vergoldet die den ansehen der monarchie
schaden könnten
viele details sind noch offen etwa wer
künftig den personenschutz zahlt bleiben
könnten zuwendungen von harrys vater
prinz charles in millionenhöhe dazu das
vermögen des paars geschätzt mehr als 20
millionen euro finanziell wird es ein
weicher fall aber in status und form ein
unerwartet harter abschied aus der
ersten reihe der reiz zum sport und der
enttäuschung bei den deutschen
handballern verstehen sie wird gerade
verarbeitet der frust ist natürlich groß
nach der ärgerlichen 24 25 niederlage
gegen kroatien und der verpassten
realistischen chance auf das em
finale dennoch gibt es eine neue
kampfansage mit vollgas in die
restlichen zwei hauptrunden spiele das
halbfinale hat die dhb auswahl zwar
abgehakt locker lassen wollen die
deutschen handballer bei dieser em aber
noch nicht morgen wartet in wien der
co-gastgeber das ist ihr spiel des
jahres und 19 allein gilt was wir für
eine antwort bereit sind zu geben prokop
appelliert an den charakter seiner
mannschaft die gegen kroatien zwar die
beste turnier leistung gezeigt einen
fünf tore vorsprung aber verspielt und
auch ein mögliches unentschieden kurz
vor schluss verpasst hat gegen
österreich und danach gegen tschechien
will deutschland selbstvertrauen tanken
für das große ziel im april die
olympia-qualifikation in berlin
im ersten sonntagsspiel der fußball
bundesliga gewinnt der fc bayern münchen
bei hertha bsc mit 4 0 und verbessert
sich auf tabellenplatz zwei vor gladbach
und vier punkte hinter spitzenreiter
leipzig die hertha nun auf 14 2 punkte
vor dem relegationsplatz
und noch zum wintersport da ist aus
deutscher sicht der weltcup doppelerfolg
im vier- oder durch die deutschen
bobfahrer das sportliche highlight des
tages schon gestern im zweier
erfolgreich gewinnt francesco friedrich
in igls auf den wettbewerb im viererbob
johannes lochner auf rang zwei und niko
walther auf dem vierten platz
komplettieren die deutsche überlegenheit
wie schon gestern gewinnt der pole dawid
kubacki auch heute das skispringen in
titisee-neustadt beste deutsche stefan
lauer auf 4 und karl geiger auf 5 der
damit im gesamtweltcup weiter vorne
liegt deutschlands rodler erleben bei
der em in lila ein sportliches debakel
johannes ludwig auf rang 8 felix loch
gar nur auf rang 14 können den neuen
europameister dominik fischnaller nur
aus der ferne beglückwünschen und die
deutschen hallenhockey spieler sind in
berlin europameister geworden ich glaube
ja bleibt noch das wetter morgen da wo
sich der zähe nebel auflöst wird es
meist freundlich der norden ist
allerdings dicht bewölkt höchstwerte 0
bis 8 grad und die weiteren aussichten
ruhiges wetter mit sonne wolken und
nebel bei ähnlichen temperaturen
das war es von uns danke dass wir bei
waren und am besten bleiben sie auch
dran
denn hier geht es jetzt weiter mit einem
zdf spezial und chuck und ab energy zum
libyen gipfel in berlin einen schönen
sonntagabend noch tschüss